lobby of Ramsey solutions and the and
Carly are with us hey guys how's life
great where y'all from we're from
Davenport Iowa Oh fun
and here to do a debt-free screen we are
and how much have you paid off two
hundred and thirty-five thousand dollars
Oh
how long did this take twenty nine
months all right making what kind of
money started at sixty and we're
probably about 140 now excellent what do
y'all do for a living I'm marketing and
communications coordinator for a health
IT company mm-hm
and I'm a territory manager for a
manufacturing company dealership for
them cool so I'm guessing you sold house
yes alright I was thinking that's
relocate for his new jobs yeah yeah
alright so what did the house sell for
53 no that's what we bought it before it
was sold for 165 just two years after we
bought it
okay 165 all right which means then that
you had about what sixty thousand bucks
that you paid off otherwise right yeah
in total with we had sixty five thousand
student loans and then seventeen
thousand and a car loan mm-hmm and some
of that got paid off with the sale the
house and ranked some of it and then the
rest of it you've cashflow yeah very
cool good for you guys so tell Chris and
I crescent me the story twenty nine
months ago what happened well at twenty
nine months ago is when we had to
actually start paying our student loans
and so we started doing that and my
brother had gone through just the book
Total Money Makeover and he gave me a
copy after I graduated mm-hmm just like
hey you know check this out it's did
great thanks for me and I I witnessed
that and him and his wife are working on
getting through all their debts as well
so we started to kind of loosely do it
we bought a car in October of the year
that we started for because we thought
we had troubles with another one anyway
so we make it really get serious about
it till last August about a year ago oh
wow really Cazale intent yeah what
caused that well so we started going
through FPU on the CD
with her friends Jacqui and Jeremy and
so shout out to them we always called it
dinner and Dave we would go their house
and listen to the CD with them cuz I
like Jenner in a bad movie yeah but we
didn't even get to see you we only got
to listen to so we wanted to have the
real experience of going through the
class so we went through it after you
stole it went to the class to two times
now yeah so once you go back second time
stay motivated encouragement of the
other people around you because you
already had the information yeah but the
first time we had to drive an hour to go
to the class and the second time there
was one in our local community so that
was a lot easier to to go to yeah okay
so what was the key element of the
little bit of the Total Money Makeover
book the dinner and Dave and then the
classes I see the progression of
intensity there what do you think was
the key element that caused you guys to
be able to get shed of all this debt we
were just starting to get more momentum
with it and as we saw that happening we
wanted to stay motivated and going
through the class and who's the hardcore
one on the budget which one of you Andy
you come in with a you come in with some
stuff occasionally and you get one pick
your lip out and go I don't want to do
this and how often does that happen not
too often anymore we're we're pretty
good at looking at our every dollar
budget now so that the the my budget
told me I could yes because you can do
it without guilt yep or without conflict
when you get home yes
you don't have to hide the target beds
under the top of the bed under the bed
market bags under the bed oh my gosh Wow
well congratulations you guys thank you
very very very well done I'm very proud
of you Chris you're getting questions
form
yeah I love the fact that you know if
you just have it in your head that
you're gonna do something you don't get
the results it's when you get intense
about it and that's so good for our
listeners to to hear so
your when you you said you were the Nazi
Andy right a little bit Nazi it might be
good for our listeners to hear how did
you lead when you were you had to maybe
question the decision tell us a little
bit about this proactive communication
what does that look like versus reactive
yeah so we were always pretty good about
being open about our communication with
our finances and so we would sit down
and and walk through that and kind of
lay out what we had for the month and
yeah typically the day or two before the
new month starts and he was always
really good about sitting me down and
kind of called it a little sort of a
date night it wasn't like too intense
either we were both pretty good about it
because I'm kind of a spender too so I
wanted to be on top of it but also I
could say four things that he wanted to
buy like the whole reason they're doing
that show yeah did be able to give more
and I'm able to enjoy your mind more
rather than all going out the door well
that's that's another key is giving the
whole time yeah well we've been able to
do this and so because we truly believe
like God is the master of our money so
now that's a big part of the nobility of
that changes your behavior - yeah
did you Barry you guys are amazing
congratulations all right Andy and Carly
Davenport Iowa you did it five hundred
and thirty-five thousand dollars
including the sale of a house but
including sixty plus thousand dollars of
cash flow in twenty nine months making
sixty to 140 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
well done well done well done
Oh